[Música]
e vou começar oficialmente já que a
gente está falando de teatro e arte eu
evoco duas falas que me marcaram a
infância
a dona baratinha ea cigarra ea formiga e
eu pergunto e vocês vão responder
mentalmente
se a gente fosse encenar uma das fábulas
a cigarra ea formiga ou a dona baratinha
quem vocês seriam com qual o personagem
vocês se identificam mais com a cigarra
ea formiga com a dona baratinha e como é
que vocês acham que o mundo ver vocês
como cigarra ea formiga bom é que já que
a gente está falando de uma fábula do
nosso imaginário infantil eu aproveito e
convido vocês a uma viagem no tempo mais
precisamente a minha infância em
curitiba
acho que é assim talvez o ano é 1977 foi
quando eu me descobri artista nesse ano
faleceram carolina de jesus clarice
lispector elvis presley anaisi mim
charlie chaplin bowie lançou heroes e o
cupim we are the champions
eu dei neste ano também de 77 a minha
primeira entrevista pro meu pai na casa
que nós morávamos chamávamos de chakra
ele fazia entrevista usando um daqueles
gravadores de rolo antigos com microfone
que era moderníssimo na época o meu pai
o jornalista ronald stresser
ele era um homem do audiovisual um dos
pioneiros
a minha mãe a minha mãe é uma diva
literalmente bom a entrevista o meu pai
gupta os anos você tem e eu 5 papai e
ele o que você quer ser quando crescer
filha e eu poeta bailarina aos cinco
anos
eu respondi poeta bailarina como se
fosse assim uma coisa só
eu depois quando eu estava viajando com
o meu pai muitos anos depois eu tinha
juntado uma grana pra dar esse presente
para ele um cruzeiro de navio
meu pai amava o mar e nós fomos só nós
dois nesse cruzeiro
bom nós dois e mais uns mil brasileiros
todos os fãs da bebel e da grande
família porque o programa tava no auge é
eu fiquei doente durante a viagem eu
passei metade da viagem ou informada da
cabine ou tirando fotos com todos os
passageiros céu fiz fora a tradicional
foto com o capitão claro que se deixava
o meu pai super orgulhoso e eu ficava
feliz por ele
um dia nós encontramos um conhecido dele
no navio também curitibano tirei foto
com a família tal aí o sujeito vira pro
meu pai pergunta mas ronaldo e medida
como é que aguenta conseguiu essa
peixada lá na globo
meu pai que conhecia toda a minha luta
para ter chegado até ali e também o
gênio da filha ele me olhou como quem
diz calma filha calma e depois eu conto
pra vocês a minha resposta vamos voltar
às fábulas
eu amava a dona baratinha a imagem dela
falava de uma mulher que talvez eu
quisesse ser com fita no cabelo e
dinheiro na caixinha mas algo não
fechava quem quer casar com a dona
baratinha que tem fita no cabelo e
dinheiro na caixinha que
fixação e arranjar marido será que ela
ela não se garante sozinha ela é uma
baratinha fashion rica ela pode
conquistar o mundo porque ela não quer
estudar fora com a sua grana empreender
abrir um calor quem vamos um centro
cultural
o problema é que nós crescemos ouvindo
histórias em que as mulheres só precisam
arranjar um bom homem para cuidar delas
e isso me incomodava
ela era poderosa eu não gosto do termo
empoderada não a gente não precisa que
ninguém nos em poder e a gente já tem
poder
basta revindica esse poder de volta pra
mim feminismo é sobre reintegração de
posse
porque a verdade é que tudo a que temos
direito já foi nosso
ou no mínimo dividido com os homens
bom eu me descobri a atriz no mundo onde
o homem no centro é o padrão ele o
protagonista o herói aquele de quem as
mulheres falam a respeito a quem desejo
e por quem brigam
crescemos aqui acreditando que somos
coadjuvantes no mundo a velha máxima por
trás de um grande homem há sempre uma
grande mulher
mas porquê porque a mulher não pode
estar lado a lado ao grande homem né
então eu passei a não identificar tanto
com a dona baratinha lutando por meu
espaço como artista e mulher no mundo
eu passei a me identificar mais com a
cigarra da fábula tem várias versões
a maioria bom a gotinha a gente já pode
se pedir algo tinha a fábula tem várias
versões
a maioria delas termina com a formiga
batendo à porta do formigueiro na cara
da cigarra congelando ali fora ea
formiga dizendo já que cantam o verão
todo agora danfe
isso me deixava furiosa que aparenta
formiga
coitada da cigarra o verão foi a sua
alta temporada com os artistas estão nas
ruas animando a vida de todos inclusive
das formigas
mas sem as versões em que as formigas
acolhem a cigarra no inverno e o funk o
formigueiro vir uma grande festa animada
pela arte da cigarra com essa do josé
paulo passos de 1989 enquanto a formiga
carrega comida para o formigueiro a
cigarra canta canta o dia inteiro a
formiga é só trabalho a cigarra é só
cantiga mas sem a cantiga da cigarra que
distrai da fadiga
seria uma barra o trabalho da formiga
tem também a versão monteiro lobato que
a moral da história é os artistas poetas
pintores músicos são as cigarras da
humanidade
eu descobri ainda que o escritor
curitibano paulo leminski que hoje
completaria 75 anos em seu livro ensaios
em seus críticos cita fábula ea mística
do trabalho abre aspas
aqui o trabalho como foi canonizado pela
revolução industrial e pela burguesia
fabril do século 19 um trabalho
policiado por relógios implacáveis e que
cobram em minutos
esse trabalho repressor dos instintos
mais básicos expressa se por exemplo no
insulto mais típico entre nós o de
vagabundo
o preço do trabalho nossa sensualidade a
nossa sensorialidade a nossa capacidade
de jogar e de brincar
bom ele continua falando sobre a mística
da poupança que ele diz como a outra
grande inimiga da criatividade artística
além de trabalhar pra burro
o imigrante poupa o animal totêmico do
imigrante é a formiga
assim se chega a uma ideologia de
poupança guardar é superior ao usufruir
freudianamente é a retenção de fezes
nosso pecado ea avareza hora
criar é esbanjar é é excesso só se cria
com excessos
o prazer é um valor em si nossa
tendência é ver a produção artística uma
coisa séria artista tem que ser
emocionante
fecha aspas questão pra mim sempre foi
que a cigarra ela também realiza o seu
trabalho como artista
isso dá muito trabalho podem acreditar
toma tempo ela está criando ensaiando e
preparando pra animal formigueiro quando
o inverno chegar e animando também o
trabalho árduo das formigas durante o
verão é uma troca é uma permuta entre a
cigarra ea formiga e ninguém ali é
vagabundo preguiçoso cada um tem sua
importância nessa sociedade a colha a
cigarra
tente imaginar o mundo sem arte paredes
vazias
você preso no engarrafamento sem o
alívio de ouvir seu som preferido na
rádio nunca dançar nem juntinho nem
sozinho só notícias na tv uma eterna
globonews nada criado para te fazer rir
se emocionar nada para aliviar a dureza
da rotina nada que seja lúdico que traga
uma reflexão ou apenas seja agradável
aos olhos e ao ouvido fora é claro a
própria natureza que essa a gente já
está destruindo vocação e talento como
falava um dos meus grandes mestres
ademar guerra que dirigiu o vampiro ea
polaquinha que eu fiz aos 19 anos no
papel da própria peça do nosso maior
cronista dalton trevisan
o ademar dia não basta ter apenas
vocação
não basta ter apenas talento é a
combinação dos dois que faz um grande
artista um grande profissional de
qualquer área
você tem que amar aquilo que você faz
além de ter aptidão e se você tiver para
o seu sustento que trabalhar com algo
que você não escolheria ainda assim viu
faça seu trabalho com amor tenha tem de
achar algum prazer naquilo tempo a
ciência e nas horas vagas dedique tempo
a sua verdadeira vocação qualquer que
seja ou se deixe simplesmente levar pelo
seu direito à pura contemplação se de
prazeres vocação é também perceber a
lembram da história do navio
bom eu respondi aquele sujeito na lata
fechada deixada meu senhor foi assim ó
aos 13 anos eu comecei no teatro amador
anos lendo estudando fazendo cursos
oficinas fono horas ensaiando decorando
textos pesquisando várias peças
aos 19 e enfrentei uma banca para me
profissionalizar
eu lutei contra a família que não
aprovava a minha escolha
fiz testes e não passei passei no teste
para a polaquinha eu mudei cidade eu
participei da inauguração de um teatro
em saiba oito horas por dia eu fazia
peça de terça a domingo
é eu passava mais tempo no teatro do que
em qualquer lugar do mundo eu cheguei a
fazer umas três sessões de peça infantil
no mesmo dia eu fiz animação de festa
infantil eu andava com um cenário de
espuma da peça no porta malas do meu
chevette que vinha quebrando até já
empurrei carro vestida de fada entre
editais não ganhei
mudei para o rio abre mão das regalias
que eu tinha em casa eu sair da minha
zona de conforto eu tive mestres e os
respeitei os ouve
eu levei currículo e foto em tudo
é produtor eu peguei muito ônibus lotado
eu me senti extremamente só mesmo
dividindo uma quitinete com seis pessoas
dormindo num colchão no chão o meu
guarda roupa era mala do lado do colchão
que fechada
virava uma escrivaninha eu resisti à
tentação de abandonar tudo e voltar
correndo para o colo da mãe e do meu pai
aí eu fiz novos amigos eu tive muito
medo eu enfrentei o perseverei eu entrei
para uma companhia de teatro
conheci outro mestre o abu dhabi jangada
e um gênio joão fonseca
fiz peças históricas com eles voltei pra
curitiba propague protagonizando o
casamento no festival de curitiba com a
ópera de arame lotada consagrada no
teatro indicada prêmios mas ainda dura e
virgen de televisão mas um teste uma
peça dirigida pelo é torben tempo mais
perto o closer e lembram que depois teve
o filme com a natalie portman
ou seja se eu fosse americana talvez eu
já tivesse sido indicada a um óscar e
foi nessa peça que o guel arraes me viu
e me chamou para fazer um teste para
bebel uns indiganção minha primeira vez
no projac foi para assinar o meu
contrato
sozinha eu comecei a trabalhar em um
vídeo um veículo novo pra mim com os dos
maiores atores da televisão brasileira
uma responsabilidade enorme e agora eu
tô aqui
aos 35 anos de idade eu dizendo pra ele
né
na viagem que eu dei de presente para o
meu pai te explicando que foi assim a
minha fechada
vocês não imaginam a cara do sujeito e
nem é do meu pai também ele não sabia
onde enfiar no fim talvez é isso que eu
tenho pra dizer que não existe fechada
existe sonho vocação dedicação e talento
vocação aliás é um excelente antídoto
para a depressão
também há medos que impulsionaram não só
paralisaram como medo de me perder
demir desperdiçara o medo de sucumbir de
não saber me reinventar e tem que
começar sempre e essa vulnerabilidade
também é o que eu tenho de melhor
então você já descobriram se vocês são
mais cigarras se vocês são mais formiga
porque eu eu descobri que apesar do
mundo me vê como cigarra
eu sou na verdade uma cigarra ea formiga
uma coisa só tipo poeta bailarina e eu
finalizo também com a comunicação préval
já fazendo tempo aliás uma arma é uma
arma significa dor morte violência um
coração é um coração e é sempre amor e
uma reverência significa respeito e
gratidão por essa troca
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]